[MUSIC PLAYING]
Listen.
We know that you love threading.
And we know that for 99%
of your threading needs,
AsyncTask is the right solution.
But for the other work, you
might need a different kind
of threading primitive.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And for the types of work that
might not deal with UI updates,
HandlerThreads are
a nifty solution.
See, when it comes
to threading work,
most devs have a
round trip model.
Now, you've got some work.
You want it tossed from the UI
thread to some other thread.
And then, when the work needs
to come back to the UI thread,
you've got to update some visual
thingamajigger or whatever.
For these types of situations,
AsyncTask is obviously
the easiest solution for you.
I mean, it wraps
up all the overhead
of pushing work from the UI
thread to a worker thread
and then getting the results
back to the UI thread.
But AsyncTask isn't
the right threading
primitive for every situation.
Consider the challenge
of getting preview frames
from your camera.
These previews are
given back to you
via the onPreviewFrame
callback, which
is invoked on the same
thread that the camera dot
open function was called on.
So if this callback were
invoked on the UI thread,
then the task of dealing
with those huge pixel arrays
would be interfering with
rendering and event processing
work.
And same thing
goes for AsyncTask.
Remember that by default,
these execute serially
on another thread, which
means that dealing with an 8
megapixels block of data
might stall other AsyncTask
packets that the UI
thread is waiting on.
So really, what you want is a
non-UI, non-AsyncTask thread
that can receive these
callbacks and potentially spend
a long time
processing that work.
And this is exactly what
HandlerThread is for.
See, a HandlerThread
is effectively
a long-running thread that
grabs work from a queue
and operates on it.
It's a combination of a few
other Android [INAUDIBLE],
namely a Looper, which keeps the
thread live and holds a message
queue and a Handler
object, which
manages how work is inserted
into that message queue.
Anyhow, getting back
to our camera example.
Once you've created
the HandlerThread,
you can delegate the camera
dot open command to it
and know that the
onPreviewFrame callback will
land on the HandlerThread
rather than the UI or AsyncTask
threads.
So if you're going to be doing
a long-running block of work
on those pixels, this
is ideal for you.
And to be clear, getting
the results of that work
back to the UI thread is
pretty straightforward.
Just pass it along with
the runOnUiThread command.
So HandlerThreads are obviously
helpful for other Android APIs
that follow a similar pattern.
But they can also be useful
for longer running, non-UI work
like compressing a
batch of user metrics
before uploading
it to your server.
If you've got other UI-specific
tasks happening on AsyncTask,
then you might not want this
longer running operation
to stall that work.
So HandlerThreads are
a good place for it.
Oh by the way, when you create
a HandlerThread, don't forget
to set its thread priority based
on the type of work it's doing.
I mean, remember, CPUs can
only handle a small number
of threads in parallel.
So setting the priority
helps the system
know the right ways to
schedule this work when
the other threads are
fighting for attention.
And that's the whole thing when
it comes to performance coding.
You have to understand
enough about the primitives
to know how they help you
and how they might hurt you.
And if it's not working, move
on to a better pattern, which
is why you should check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns videos.
And don't forget to ask the
hard threading questions
on the Google+
community, as well.
So keep calm.
Profile your code.
And always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]